Lucia: 然后再去转一下
Lucia: And then turn it around a bit.
Tasha: 是不都扔了
Tasha: Didn't you throw them all away?
Jake:耶你气的
Jake: Yeah, you got angry.
Jake:你眼你眼镜呢我靠
Jake: Where are your glasses? Damn.
Shure: 落床上了
Shure: Left them on the bed.
Jake:卖买瓜丢了个眼镜
Jake: Selling melons, lost a pair of glasses.
Jake:1234
Jake: 1234.
Jake:5
Jake: 5.
Jake:哎呀哎呀
Jake: Oh dear, oh dear.
Jake:插线板拔了吧
Jake: Unplug the power strip.
Jake:咱把插线板都都给拔了吧
Jake: Let's unplug all the power strips.
Shure: 然后打车票子啥的你就留好
Shure: Then keep the taxi receipts and stuff.
Jake:啊嗨嗨
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 到时候跟那个小畅报
Shure: Later, report it to Little Chang.
Shure: 啾啾啾
Shure: Choo choo choo.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What's this?
Shure: 那个打孔器
Shure: That’s a puncher.
Shure: 打耳洞的
Shure: For ear piercing.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 真的呀
Shure: Yes, really.
Shure: 你看那不还有碘伏呢吗
Shure: Look, there's even iodine.
Shure: 然后涂完碘伏然后把耳耳朵夹在里面
Shure: You apply iodine and clip your ear in it.
Shure: 然后一摁
Shure: Then press.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 对啊就穿过去了
Shure: Yeah, it goes through.
Shure: 没想到吧
Shure: Didn't expect that, right?
Jake:哼哼确实没想到哼
Jake: Hmm, indeed didn't expect that.
Lucia: 哎我是不是把那个啥放在
Lucia: Did I leave that thing...
Jake:确实很难想这个
Jake: Hard to imagine this.
Tasha: 我真的想打个耳洞
Tasha: I really want to get my ears pierced.
Lucia: 放在放在哪了
Lucia: Leave it, leave it where?
Shure: 试试
Shure: Try it.
Shure: 是不是差点就信了
Shure: Did you almost believe it?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha!
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure: 怎么样怎么样这个
Shure: How about this?
Shure: 骗人的本领
Shure: The art of deception.
Shure: 撒谎不眨眼
Shure: Lying without blinking.
Tasha: 甩了他他不专心
Tasha: Dump him, he's not focused.
Shure: 得得得得得得我的心
Shure: Alright, alright, alright, my heart.
Alice:这有用吗这还
Alice: Is this even useful?
Shure: 猜猜这一坨是谁压的
Shure: Guess who placed this lump here?
Shure: 是的没错就是我
Shure: Yes, it's me.
Shure: 我以为他整
Shure: I thought he...
Alice:这坨东西还有用吗
Alice: Is this lump still useful?
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 很有用
Shure: Very useful.
Alice:搁哪
Alice: Where to put it?
Shure: 这几个是谢彬竹的那个我靠
Shure: These few are from Xie Binzhu, oh my.
Shure: 还有一个应该
Shure: There should be one more.
Alice:那要不你给他收起来
Alice: How about you keep it for him?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 这四个是谢彬竹的
Shure: These four are Xie Binzhu's.
Shure: 这个是杨老板
Shure: This one is Jake's.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 杨老板这个是什么的
Shure: Jake, what's this one for?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:12345有5个
Jake: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, there are 5 here.
Jake:这边不用翻
Jake: No need to flip here.
Jake:但是没地放
Jake: But there's no place to put them.
Jake:放后面随便找地放
Jake: Just find a spot at the back.
Jake:这一层就5个
Jake: There are 5 on this level.
Jake:这种目一词
Jake: This word...
Alice:这是不是搬下去啊
Alice: Should we move this down?
Alice:这个木凳子
Alice: This wooden stool.
Alice:般一个
Alice: Move one.
Shure: 这也说不用
Shure: No need for this either.
Shure: 搬下去就放这了
Shure: Just move it down and put it here.
Shure: 哎呀音箱拔下来
Shure: Oh no, the speaker is unplugged.
Shure: 哎音响已经拔了
Shure: Oh, the speaker is already unplugged.
Shure: 音响我想直接寄回家了
Shure: I think I'll just ship the speakers back home.
Shure: 反正我在学校应该也用不到了吧
Shure: Anyway, I probably won't need them at school.
Shure: 因为没买到刮刮乐
Shure: Because I couldn't buy the scratch cards.
Shure: 所以就给大家买个刮
Shure: So I bought this for everyone instead.
Alice:哈哈哈好谢谢
Alice: Hahaha, okay, thanks!
哈哈哈
(Laughter)
Lucia: 这粘哪呀我靠
Lucia: Where do I stick this? Damn.
Shure: 但是我买的这个盒子我已经找不到了
Shure: But I can't find the box I bought.
Shure: 怎么能给他安全的寄回去
Shure: How can I safely ship it back?
Shure: 我总不能背着他背回去吧
Shure: I can't possibly carry it back, right?
其他人：嗯你要是
Others: Well, if you...
Shure: 我不会的哈哈
Shure: I won't do that, haha.
其他人：不是我是说你要是从学校寄的话
Others: No, I mean if you ship it from school...
其他人：我那倒是有箱子还有泡沫纸
Others: I have a box and some bubble wrap.
Shure: 行从你那薅薅吧
Shure: Alright, I'll take some from you then.
Shure: 哎这应该也不缺什么泡沫纸
Shure: Hey, we shouldn't lack any bubble wrap.
Shure: 盒子什么的东西
Shure: Or boxes and stuff.
其他人：你就算没有泡沫纸
Others: Even if you don't have bubble wrap...
其他人：你把你不需要衣服在旁边垫一下
Others: You can pad it with clothes you don't need.
Shure: 道理
Shure: Good idea.
Shure: 你好聪明
Shure: You're so smart.
Shure: 你又做那个青蛙脸干什么
Shure: Why are you making that frog face again?
Shure: 帮我帮我
Shure: Help me, help me.
Shure: 低了一下这个尾巴
Shure: Lower the tail a bit.
Tasha: 好像没什么要忙的了
Tasha: Seems like there's nothing much left to do.
Alice:啊啊
Alice: Ahh.
Tasha: 我说好像没什么要忙的了
Tasha: I said, seems like there's nothing much left to do.
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: All done.
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: Now...
Lucia: 它的整齐程度就和昨天一模一样
Lucia: It's just as tidy as it was yesterday.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 我我现在是不是要到外面还是
Lucia: So, should I go outside now or...
Jake:呃还没
Jake: Uh, not yet.
Jake:还有几个人
Jake: There are still a few people.
Jake:呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:等人齐了一起走
Jake: We'll go together once everyone's here.
Lucia: 放这吧他还可以出镜一下
Lucia: Just put it here, it can still be on camera.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:微微准备下去吧
Jake: Tasha, get ready to go.
Jake:在吗
Jake: Are you there?
Jake:准备下去吧
Jake: Get ready to go down.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:走走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:走啦走啦走啦走啦走啦
Jake: Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Tasha: 我不下去行不行
Tasha: Can I not go down?
Jake:哎这是一个好主意
Jake: Ah, that's a good idea.
Jake:那你不能动
Jake: But you can't move.
Jake:你得是可以
Jake: You have to stay still.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:可以可以可以可以可以可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 我下去吧
Lucia: I'll go down.
Lucia: 哈哈难度好高哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, it's so difficult, haha.
Jake:这个就是一个示意图形就是
Jake: This is just an indicative diagram.
Jake:那你到时候就这么坐着
Jake: So you just sit like this.
Tasha: 我不动
Tasha: I won't move.
Jake:你扒东好你扒东
Jake: You hold on tight, okay?
Lucia: 哇我真的对这个非常满意
Lucia: Wow, I'm really satisfied with this.
Lucia: 再给我多点时间
Lucia: Give me more time.
Lucia: 我甚至还能把那个鱼和海浪
Lucia: I can even decorate the fish and waves more realistically.
Lucia: 给他装饰的更像一点
Lucia: To make them look more realistic.
Lucia: 就是我应该扫一下
Lucia: I should scan it.
Lucia: 你用的是哪个软件
Lucia: Which software are you using?
Jake:就是3D scan
Jake: It's 3D scan.
Jake:呃对对对
Jake: Uh, yes, yes.
Lucia: threed scanner那个
Lucia: That 3D scanner?
Jake:3D SCAN
Jake: 3D SCAN.
Lucia: OK我之前用过那个
Lucia: OK, I've used that before.
Tasha: 我也用过
Tasha: I've used it too.
Tasha: 我帮你扫另一个房间吧
Tasha: I'll help you scan the other room.
Tasha: 哦不行
Tasha: Oh, no.
Tasha: 要要一个设备扫
Tasha: You need one device to scan.
Lucia: 他对他要扫一个连续的文件
Lucia: Yes, it needs to be a continuous file.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 我是ready scatter
Lucia: I'm ready to scan.
Lucia: 应该还有
Lucia: There should be more.
Lucia: 我上次那个啥的也有可能没有了
Lucia: Last time I did it, it might not be there anymore.
Lucia: 因为我这个软件好久没用了
Lucia: I haven't used this software in a long time.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:我要上个厕所
Alice: I need to go to the bathroom.
Alice:这个不可以录
Alice: This part can't be recorded.
Jake:好好没问题没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem, no problem.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:可以不录
Jake: We won't record it.
Jake:我要开始扫了可以了吗
Jake: I'm going to start sweeping now, okay?
Jake:那你就坐着
Jake: Just sit there.
Jake:你不能动
Jake: You can't move.
Jake:你摆个好pose
Jake: Strike a good pose.
Jake:哈哈哈你总之是不能动
Jake: Hahaha, you really can't move.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:别都行
Jake: It's fine.
Jake:别的干啥都行
Jake: You can do anything else.
Jake:你真不能动啊
Jake: You really can't move.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 到我这的时候喊我呀
Tasha: Call me when it's my turn.
Jake:你都行
Jake: You're fine.
Jake:你可以不动
Jake: You can stay still.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Jake:哎我靠
Jake: Hey, what the heck?
Jake:你可以不动
Jake: You can stay still.
Jake:也可以躲着我
Jake: Or you can hide from me.
Jake:那你就不动吧
Jake: Just don't move.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 我动了吗这样算动吗
Tasha: Am I moving? Does this count as moving?
Jake:哎嘿嘿
Jake: Hey, hehe.
Jake:不算不算不算
Jake: It doesn't count, it doesn't count.
Jake:行我先扫你吧好吧
Jake: Okay, I'll scan you first, alright?
Tasha: 我这边结束了吗
Tasha: Am I done here?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:还没开始
Jake: Not yet.
Jake:按了按了按了
Jake: Pressed it, pressed it.
Jake:开始了开始了
Jake: It's starting, it's starting.
Tasha: 开始了
Tasha: It's starting.
Jake:别动不准动
Jake: Don't move, you can't move.
Tasha: 结束了吗
Jake:结束你可以动
Jake: We're done, you can move now.
Jake:你动也不能出来哦
Jake: You can't move out of bed.
Jake:你只能在床上动
Jake: You can only move while in bed.
Jake:你不能露出头
Jake: You can't stick your head out.
Tasha: 我露出头会怎么样
Tasha: What happens if I stick my head out?
Jake:你就会悬一个你的头
Jake: You will hang your head somewhere.
Jake:在某一个地方
Jake: In a certain place.
Tasha: 好我同意
Tasha: Okay, I agree.
Jake:你统一选一个头是吧
Jake: So you agree to hang your head somewhere, right?
Tasha: 同意了
Tasha: I agree.
Jake:同意的是什么
Jake: What exactly are you agreeing to?
Jake:别动别动别动别动别动
Jake: Don't move, don't move, don't move, don't move, don't move.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 耶
Tasha: Yay.
Tasha: 我的天那
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: hello
Tasha: Hello.
Jake:hello
Jake: Hello.
Tasha: OK你不在
Tasha: OK, you're not here.
Tasha: OK come on
Tasha: OK, come on.
Tasha: 不要动
Tasha: Don't move.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 睡觉了睡觉的话就没办法戴眼镜了
Tasha: If we're going to sleep, we can't wear glasses.
Tasha: 对吧
Tasha: Right?
Tasha: 好吧那我们只能关掉了
Tasha: Alright, then we can only turn it off.
Tasha: 困了
Tasha: I'm sleepy.
Tasha: 今个起太早了
Tasha: Got up too early today.